Joe Rogan and Matt Walsh disagree over
gay marriage so I'm excited to watch it
the joke I'm excited to hear these
points of view because I The Joe Rogan
Experience problem in being a Christian
that other Christians are against gay
marriage and I'm like
calm down yeah nobody's getting hurt and
my gay friends are the nicest people and
best contributors to society so shut up
but let's see what they have to say The
Joe Rogan Experience I think of marriage
is is a certain thing which is the um
the context for for procreation for the
for the the building of the the nuclear
family what about people that get
married that don't have kids are you
opposed to that what if they get married
they decide you know we don't need kids
no Rogan asks like the best questions of
any interviewer he's so awesome yeah
he's very polite and straightforward
about it I like it
you get your tubes tied let's travel the
world well what do you mean am I opposed
to it I mean I I think that uh that
every married couple should be open to
life but what if they don't want to do
you opposed to them being married if
marriage is only for procreation and to
bond a family together what about people
that are deeply in love that never want
to have children I don't think it's it's
not only procreation but that is one of
the fundamental definitional aspects of
it of course there's more to marriage
just than that and what about people
that are infertile they've fallen in
love and they realize that they can have
babies they don't really necessarily
want to adopt is that okay for them to
be married because then you're by
definition marriage falls into a
completely different thing because then
it's a bond of love it's a union of Love
sure I mean that doesn't change the
nature of of marriage though it's a
little bit like
um I say that uh uh what's the
definition of a woman well a woman is
someone who by her nature can conceive
children in her womb and bear children
and then the response is always what
about women who are infertile does that
does that destroy your definition of
woman and it it doesn't because you know
it's still it's still a woman's nature
to Bear children not every woman will
and there will be disease and
infertility and and old age and all
these things that will preclude that but
it's still it's still of her nature to
do so and I would say the same thing for
marriage I mean it's it is natural in a
marriage for for procreation to occur
it's not always going to happen in
reality though but that's still that's
still one of the natural functions of
marriage and and uh married couples who
can't conceive children there are other
ways to be parents like adoption for
example if they want to right but if
people want to be married and don't want
to ever have children are you opposed to
them being married well I'm not I'm not
I wouldn't Advocate a law that would
prevent it but would it change the
definition of what their marriage is to
you because they don't want to have a
family they just want to have a loving
Bond I think this would be a cop people
or they do that though to people like is
that a thing where people get married
and then don't have kids is that common
absolutely that's common yes yeah I
don't know how common it is but I I know
it is absolutely a thing I have a couple
that I'm very good friends with man and
woman married for many years they agreed
in advance that they didn't want
children and voila no kids happy
marriage that's fascinating let's keep
going well that is rejecting uh one of
the fundamental aspects of marriage and
they they should be they they should be
open to life I would hope that in the
future they would be but but isn't that
just a personal choice I mean you can
have a very fulfilling life if you just
follow your Pursuits and your dreams and
your your interests and you find someone
that shares those interests with you and
you share time together it's very
fulfilling it's a loving yeah it's a
it's a person it's a personal choice and
that I'm not advocating for like a law
that says you if you're a marriage you
have to have you have to have X number
of kids but then why are you opposed to
two gay people doing that well because
because again it's it's it's not about
Choice it's about what this institution
marriage is an institution and what is
it and what purpose does it serve I do
not agree with tearing down or or
changing this definition especially
because the people who have changed the
definition haven't come up with a new
one so they say well that's not what
marriage is I love Matt and I normally
am in many many cases I'm in lockstep
with him but in this case I think that
Joe is just trampling him and I think
that Matt's arguments aren't holding
water what do you think yeah I mean I
don't really I don't want to get married
personally because I don't want to have
a contract between me and the government
about a girl that I'm with why the [ __ ]
would I sign a piece of paper that is
giving her 50 of this stuff I can sign a
will that says if I die she gets it
because you know obviously if like I die
and you know you want your partner to
have the stuff that was yours but why
why would I sign get married to a woman
I don't see the incentive for it like I
don't like the tax benefits okay
if you want to create a traditional it's
funny because I see your eyes lighting
up around this traditional lifestyle and
around the religion things that we're
talking about on our other videos yet at
the same time you're still determined to
to fight against that and not and and
resist it and that's something you're
gonna have to in time resolve for
yourself because you're young you're
[ __ ] 19 like you can't figure all of
these things out religion God family I
know everything you know oh yeah I hear
you you know so I know but I can see
that conflict that I don't even know if
you can see it no I know what you're
talking about I just like I I personally
just don't see the incentive for getting
like married with like a piece of paper
to the government I just don't like it's
if it's a love between me and this
person why do I need to get the US
government more involved in my [ __ ] I
just don't see how a gay marriage in any
way damages a straight marriage I don't
I don't see it at all it doesn't make
any sense to me it just seems to me that
people want to be look if you if you
wanted to look at logic especially in
our modern society which is pretty
[ __ ] when it comes to relationships
it's somewhere in the neighborhood of 50
of all marriage is in a divorce anyway
they don't make it you know why wouldn't
I want to I don't know if anything would
damage marriage and damage the
institution of marriage it's the option
of divorce I don't think gay people and
gay people getting married in any way
shape or form changes a bond that you
have with your wife it's just called
marriage it's a human invented thing if
we decide that gay people can get
married too I just don't see how it
damages anything I don't think it tears
down the definition of marriage in any
way it just opens up the possibility
that people who are gay won't be
discriminated against yeah I definitely
agree with Joe here like I I've
personally never been against gay
marriage I don't really careful we're
not even a little bit it's like never
not for a second we have I've never
taught you that and I have never
believed that my whole life and I know
that's because I grew up in Brooklyn New
York and I was in Manhattan a lot and we
just had all kinds of people and that
was a a mecca for being whoever the [ __ ]
you wanted to be so I was used to it I
didn't grow up in you know rural
Oklahoma where that was like you say
strange there back then yeah like the
LGB is different from the TQ plus like
it's just different yeah it's a
different thing it's a different thing
all together I am I and you were never
taught that and you growing up in a city
like we it wasn't even a thing it wasn't
even a conversation like it was just
people were people do you remember it
used to just be LGB I didn't even know
if it was LGB we didn't even have that
back in my day it wasn't we didn't have
all these [ __ ] labels it was it was
LGB and then it was LGBT and then they
added the queue and I'm like queer like
isn't gay queer like what are you
[ __ ] with and then it's AI plus and I
don't even know what that and then it
was plus and then yeah they added the
plus because they got so many freaking
ridiculous they got so ridiculous that
they just were just like you know what
guys we're just gonna put a plus sign
here and that means all of you because
they all wanted a label and they all
wanted it listen that's a whole other
thing and that is that is what's still
keeping Matt Walsh I think the tqai plus
and how cartoonish that whole world has
become has hurt the lgbs so badly
because they're still attached to them
they're like do you ever see like or
hear about a dog that was tied to a a
car bumper well the owner went into the
store and then came out and forgot the
dog was tied to the car bumper and drove
away and then the dog just got dragged
for miles until all that's what the L
the TQ eyes whatever are doing to the
lgbs like they're just like ragging them
through the [ __ ] mud with their
insanity and they have they're innocent
they have nothing to do with this kind
of insanity and cartoonish [ __ ] so
they're associ I'm sorry an insane
analogy well that's what's happening
because you still now you have them all
lumped in together and Matt Walsh is
hard against the tqi8 and I get it
because again they're cartoonish and
ridiculous and trying to over sexualize
children the gays never did that they
never wanted children involved in it
they just wanted rights they just wanted
to live their lives freely and be able
to be not be discriminated in adoption
and marriage and all those things
because they were just loving people who
had different sexual orientations so
Matt Walsh has to learn how to separate
those two in his mind because I don't
like his take on this I would agree that
um divorce especially uh you know
there's no fault divorce rampant divorce
I don't think it's as high as 50 I know
that that's the that's often quoted I'm
not sure where that comes from but um it
is high it's like it's too high and
Chris Rock has a great joke about that
he said those are just the people with
the courage to get out it's like how
many cowards stay but it's also it's
also true that the advocates for what we
call now traditional marriage which I
just call marriage but the advocates for
traditional marriage put themselves at a
disadvantage by allow especially in the
churches like allowing this rampant
divorce to occur um and then you've all
you've already sort of given up on some
marriage is supposed to be monogamous
and uh and permanent as well as
procreative well you've given up my
monogamy and permanence and so now it's
not that's that's two of the three legs
gone and so now this assault was waged
on the procreative part of it and it was
just it was it was difficult to
withstand it because the institution had
already been weakened so I agree with
you there my answer to that is to try to
reinforce what marriage is not to just
give up on it entirely and I I still
think you're left with this question of
like if marriage is not what I'm saying
it is why do we even need it what's the
point I mean you're saying it's a it's a
man-made institution like the way that
you're presenting it it's it's also it's
a totally meaningless institution no
they don't need it at all no it's not
meaningless because it means something
to the people that get married so it's
just it's just a subjective symbolic
thing I mean what yeah so it's kind of
what it is look there's a massive
responsibility when you're married and
when you have children to keep your
family together and you raise and keep
everybody happy and healthy and this
great reward to that but it doesn't
always work out it's not it's not a it's
people change people are [ __ ] up it
doesn't it doesn't always work and so I
don't think it should be outlawed
because 50 of the people fall apart just
like I don't think it has any effect
whatsoever on a straight couple if a gay
couple decides that they want to make it
official yeah and that's what it is to
them it gives them a feeling two things
one no a gay couple getting married has
no negative effect on straight marriage
none [ __ ] zero so anybody that says
it does you they have never come up with
a good explanation or even one good uh
you know really negative effect that any
of us could understand never they just
say it it threatens the institution of
marriage no it doesn't no it doesn't
second four people that are um in in in
the church there is a process called
pre-cana when you get engaged and you go
for Pre-K and counseling and it it's
it's kind of ironic because you go and
you sit with the priest and you get you
go through this process of getting
counseled before you get married to make
sure that you guys are really you know
understand each other and you're
compatible and it's kind of ironic that
a man who's never been married who's
been forbidden from being married is
counseling you to make sure are just
going to be solid it's like going to
college just for business studies from a
person who could never give a business a
foot yes right being taught right
exactly what you said that before it is
a running but it's uh it's false aside I
I really I really think there's probably
tremendous value in being able to go and
you know sit down before you get married
and have real conversations about
marriage and making sure you're on the
same page and you understand and want
all the same things I think that would
help the divorce rate if more people did
that maybe not have a priest do it maybe
have I don't know who would do it but
somebody that actually has experienced
marriage but anyway that would maybe
help with the divorce rate make
marriages more solid to begin with and
then it would kind of give more
credibility to the institution of
marriage to begin with and then Matt
would have a better shot of Defending it
but even still there's absolutely no
problem with gay marriage and then
you've got the biblical people who like
I think it was mentioned once or twice
in the Bible that mentioned late with
men like you know what they mentioned so
many others oh that's a good point so
much more important they mentioned I
remember in religion in school they
taught us how gay marriage is like
essentially or like gay sex is
essentially the same sin as like
masturbation it's like you're gonna get
so mad over this but [ __ ] everyone
does the other thing it's mentions
either once or twice in the Bible but
it's if you look at money money is money
is mentioned a bazillion times in the
Bible because they talk it talks about
how money is tied to Godliness and how
we and all the money we have is belongs
to God and how we're supposed to use it
we're basically his stewards here on
Earth and all that so you know like calm
down about that it was mentioned once or
twice like calm down it is not the most
important thing in the Bible and the
people that really hang their you know
are ready to [ __ ] die on that hill
just to kill gay marriage like I'm not
on board with them that they're accepted
and appreciated and that they're not
discriminated against because they
happen to be homosexual but what you're
articulating to me is the damage that's
done by gay marriage to the institution
of marriage but how is it done how is
that in any way damage straight people
because we are making the institution
meaning but it's not meaningless well
but you're just very meaningful to the
people that have it subjective symbolic
and it's about your own personal
feelings isn't it though well no I I
would say that it's not it's well if
it's not subjective and it's not
symbolic it's it's it it codifies and
protects and uh gives a name to a a
thing that actually exists which is
which are you know man woman couples
creating people creating creating babies
um but not always right but again that's
that's still that's still the nature of
the Union so but what are the percentage
of people today that are married that
don't have children I bet it's pretty
high amongst heterosexuals probably is
there something wrong with that I think
there is something wrong with that I
think it there's something wrong with
you know getting married and saying or
just we don't We're not gonna have any
kids at all but why is there something
wrong with that if someone's personal
choice why would that why is it wrong
that two people are like you know I am
deeply committed to work and I don't
want to sacrifice any of my career and I
don't want to ruin a kid because I'm
constantly at the office but that's
where I get deep satisfaction and and
and that's that's what I'm focused on
and the woman says that's great because
I don't want children either I really am
attached to my interest in my career and
what I like to do that's not damaging
your relationship with your wife and
your family it's I don't certainly I
certainly don't think of it as a threat
just seems like empty though like to be
honest like imagine getting old and
you're like that's all you have is like
your career like that just I don't know
and you don't have like a cool family
and stuff like I look at family
gatherings I look like my uncles and
their kids not everyone has kids and
it's like I don't know I think how is
that not what you would want I mean I
guess whatever it's your [ __ ] choice
but I don't see that as more more uh
fulfilling we've been really spoiled by
our very rich and robust family
experience I mean everybody like we have
so much fun at family events it's
probably people with lame families both
sides right so maybe those people didn't
have the blessing of experiencing that
so they don't know no exactly but that's
what I'm saying is like I want to keep
that [ __ ] going and then it'll be like
my cousins all of their kids and then my
kids and right because you've had that
fun but you know not everybody has so so
the people that haven't going out there
and and or or for whatever reason they
have chosen not to do that does not
damage your desire to have you know to
keep the the Traditions going and keep a
big family and make sure that when
there's a family party it's robust and
there's [ __ ] laughter and noise and
everybody's there Joe is right it's like
the diversity and the desires and where
people land in marriage is is okay and
one doesn't hurt the other I think they
all just need to be respected and as and
and for Matt walls to diminish another
couple's left so you could have one
couple over here who are married men and
women they've got three kids and they're
doing the traditional thing and they
[ __ ] hate each other to death and
they look at each other every morning
and they're like I wish you would choke
on your [ __ ] breakfast and then
you've got another couple a gay couple
over here with no kids and they're they
laugh together over breakfast and they
love each other how how is this one over
here better it's not Matt's got to calm
down yeah it's uh it is a personal
choice right but shouldn't people be
allowed to make those personal choices
like isn't that a fundamental aspect of
what it means to be American to have
that freedom right yeah but right now
we're not talking about what people are
allowed to do I'm not saying well we're
talking about marriage gay marriage okay
we were just discussing straight couples
who treat a couple of students that's
also a personal freedom issue isn't it
yeah but and I'm not saying that that
straight couple should be legally
required to have kids but I you know if
you're asking me do I think it's the
right choice to just get married and
choose not to have kids ever I I do not
think that that's the right choice am I
it's their it's their choice but people
can make choices that are wrong um and
you can disagree why is it wrong that
they have a fulfilling and wonderful
life together all right they're kind of
going in circles so we can cut it off
yeah I hear what Joe Rogan is saying too
where he's like the the careers and all
that [ __ ] but I just don't think that
that's fulfilling it's just being all in
on your career like but he was just
using career as an example so other
people may be married and and they
they're they want to do missionary work
and they want to help people and they
want to go out and help people and be in
foreign countries and like being like
the proverbial Peace Corps forever and
they can't do that with children or they
think they can't do that with children
for whatever so it may not just be
career so so keep in mind that that was
just a placeholder okay it doesn't
really matter if that is what fulfills
people let them be fulfilled by that all
right thank you guys for watching make
sure you like subscribe if you enjoy the
video if you don't enjoy the video don't
subscribe if you want to learn social
media and some of the marketing tips
that I use join the Discord and you can
drop videos for us to react to there you
guys have been letting it up lately
that's where I've been going to find all
videos and follow me on Instagram so
thank you guys for close to 100K
okay you guys are the best
[Music]
[Music]